[Music]
hey shawn what's up howard dawson hey
we've got a guest on today uh he doesn't
really need an introduction everybody's
dealt with him on some level or someone
like him um we have
we have actually the original member of
shadow crew brett johnson on today and
you're like who's shadow yeah they like
a breakdancing group yeah they were
they're breaking boys they were real big
with public enemy so
we've got we've got him on today we'll
start with this godfather of cybercrime
he invented the phishing email so every
email that you see
kind of generated from this man's brain
okay thank you thank you brett
so many of our listeners those of us
jason howard and myself we are very
grateful for your contributions yes so
today let's try to help today we have
ourselves a criminal
love it but we got ourselves a computer
criminal so welcome mr johnson
hey guys i appreciate it i don't know i
don't know it's it's starting out bad
you know no he needs no introduction he
already ripped all his asses off that's
that's bad starting out with well you i
mean you probably did rip a few people
off didn't you
mo more than i more than i've got
fingers and toes yeah it's nothing to be
proud of and
you know served my time about it and
been able to turn things around i was
given enough help trying to turn things
around that
these days i work on the good guys side
of things well that's called a white hat
hacker is that what you are
i'll never be a white hat i'll never be
and and simply because you know so so
i'm they i was recently named chief
criminal officer of arcos labs what that
actually means is is hey i'm not allowed
to look at data i can't get sensitive
information i can't get anything because
our clients deal with insurance
companies that won't allow that
so i'll never be the white hat guy i'll
always be the eternal you know gray hat
because
chief of criminality chief of
criminality exactly right well yeah yeah
so brett obviously you do have an
amazing story um just as howard pointed
out i mean you were back doing
stuff before it uh
i guess exploded the way it has now and
we'll kind of get into some statistics
that i saw that i read earlier today
even the difference in scamming from
2021 to 2020 i mean just how huge it has
grown even on a yearly basis let alone
from when
you started back in the early 2000s
but right here on cocktails and
cocktails we always enjoy a nice
beverage
and uh howard doss once you tell
everybody what we're having here today
it's a little different than from what
we typically like to sip on some
bodington's pub ale and as you said it's
uh smooth and creamy but it's it's got
something in it so it's got that little
nitrogen pack so when you pop it it
pours like it's yeah straight from draft
so brett cheers to you i'm going to try
that yeah yeah yeah
we'll send you one yeah he's uh he's not
having one with us
all right brett so
uh man just kind of give us a little
rundown about yourself i mean were you
one of these guys that was uh you know
when you hear one let me put myself
included when people think of internet
you know scams
um it's all these computer whiz kids and
you know hacking and blah blah blah you
know that type of stuff so how did you
get started into this what's your
background
uh background
started crime when i was 10 years old
i'm from eastern kentucky eastern
kentucky
so i don't know if anyone is really
aware that we have parts in this country
that it's hard to get a job and that
when it is hard to get a job you've got
an industrious type people in the area
that sometimes result to some sort of
scams hustles or frauds
to generate income i'm from eastern
kentucky and this is one of these areas
it's not unlike the panhandle of florida
parts of louisiana maybe parts of texas
where if you're not fortunate enough to
have a job you may be involved in a scam
hustle fraud whatever you want to call
it my mother was basically the captain
of the entire fraud industry there and
i'm talking about a woman who uh at one
point she steals a 108 thousand pound
caterpillar d9 bulldozer
at another point
yeah that's mom that's mommy
speed chase did you get a ride to school
on it
oh man i mean you've never seen a woman
before until you've seen one on
you know
i've seen some women
so that's uh you know she she did that
she takes a slip and ball and
convenience store she insurance fraud i
mean pimping
she pimped her neighbor out at one point
that's mom you know that's my mom
and my dad my dad was a good guy he just
you want to call him whipped or whatever
but he loved my mom so much he was
scared of losing her so he would co-sign
on to whatever crime she wanted to
commit and
if she wanted to abuse someone he
wouldn't step in the way so my my first
crime my mom had left my dad
mom you sleep me i was 10 my sister
denise nine
she used to leave us at home for days at
a time we didn't have any food in the
house denise walks in one day she's got
a pack of pork chops and i'm like
where'd you get that and she's like i
stole it and i'm like shit show me how
you did that
so she she takes me over shows me how
she steals food and i'm like good idea
let's do that so we look across the way
there's a kmart over there and that
becomes books games jewelry music toys
everything else
mom comes home sees everything we've
stolen asked where it came from i stand
up we found it she's like shit no you
didn't find that denise stands up we
stole it my mom looks at my sister show
me how you did that and
and she joined she starts running us as
little shoplifters and she goes to get
her mother as well so yeah man so we
were this little intergenerational
shoplifting ring in eastern kentucky and
that's where my crimes began right there
and i kept going i mean i don't blame my
my parents on my choices as an adult but
when you're a child
you can't help that you know you're
going to do what's what the circle of
adults around you are doing my sister
she had the exact same upbringing that i
did she goes out other than that
shoplifting she doesn't break the law
anymore she goes off to be a teacher a
parent very good citizen me
i kept on going and
so i grew up knowing how to do insurance
fraud from arson to faking accidents
faking stolen cars trafficking drugs uh
document forgery charity fraud illegally
mining coal
i mean all these people
no no no
hold on all the other stuff so so brett
i don't know you know we don't know one
another i was a cop for 25 years i just
retired so all the different things
you're talking about all the different
fraud the the families that do in fact
commit even just said shoplifting rings
you know things like that together um
the slip and fault before i was a police
officer i had a stint where i worked in
a grocery store and i know the grocery
store that we worked for if there was a
slip and fall there they automatically
offered 10 grand to them i mean that's
what their insurance automatically
offered right up front was 10 000 bucks
just to settle and so it is that's you
know for people that are scamming it's
an easy ten dollars or ten thousand
bucks
now
the the coal one that's the first
haven't heard of that one i know uh well
aware kentucky bourbon coal things like
that there's some great musicians we
like from kentucky that's right
that literally that thing about that
type of stuff about the coal industry
and whatnot so
wha
how's the coal scam work basically
that's a unique one that's not happening
you know brooklyn new york or los
angeles or tulsa oklahoma
yeah so what happens is is my mom
meets this man that worked for a coal
company his name was jimmy and they got
married my mom talks him into quitting
his job and going into the coal business
she was convinced he could be a very
successful coal miner so she uh they
they
scammed their way into two pieces of
equipment one being the stolen d9
bulldozer so
they
scan their way into two pieces of
equipment which basically requires a
loader and a dozer all right now the
scam comes in when you're illegally
mining you have to be permitted for that
and typically for that small of a
business you're getting a two acre
permit and back then it cost about
thirty five hundred dollars so you'd pay
thirty five hundred dollars put up a
bond for that
for that two acre per minute and it
required you to reclaim the land after
you got through the strip mining
operation which can be very expensive a
lot of it operators simply don't have
the money to do that so what you do is
is you you engage in this thing called
wildcatting which is illegally mining
coal without the permits so you have to
and and the scam works you have to you
have to get truck drivers you have to
find a cold tipple that will buy the
coal and that's not hard to do that
either you typically just go up and say
hey i've got you know i'm looking at you
know 300 400 tons of coal what will you
give me for it and
you have the coal tested for btu prices
at that point and then you deliver the
coal ones such as such a date and then
they cut you a check from that point so
it it sounds it sounds more
sophisticated and probably more romantic
than it is
it sounds like work hey it's a hustle
it's work it's a hustle
i mean it is a strip mining operation
sans
the the government permits coming in
they all want their money man you
remodel your house nowadays the city
wants permits you know it's things like
that figure it and i'm sure it's the
same way with building you know permit
building for building for permits for
building and everything else like that
but you think about it a lot of people
simply can't afford that and you're in
an area and i'm not trying to justify
the crime but it is what it is you you
take these people that
back when they didn't understand what
coal was
you've got these big people these big
companies coming in buying
mineral rights for pennies on the dollar
so now you've got a whole group of
people in eastern kentucky where they're
being mined out they don't benefit from
the the coal that's being extracted at
all except working to extract the coal
and you've got somebody that's trying to
run a company well they ain't got the
money to buy your friggin permits and i
i i'm as i'm as much a supporter of the
client as everybody else
but nobody gives a shit about the client
if they can't put about the climate if
they can't put food on the table
so
you know that's that's at the end of the
day that's that's what was going on and
of all the crimes i committed that's the
one i'll justify the most is these
people who get out there and actually
try to
to make some money either logging or
if it is wildcatting coal or whatever
because that's damn hard work at the end
of the day
hell yeah well last thing we're going to
say about cole i'm going to do a
shameless pug plug for uh tyler childers
he has a fantastic song called cole so
anybody out there listening you're not
familiar with tyler childers you're not
familiar with that song listen to it it
literally talks about that dude dude
he's fantastic he's a ginger but he is a
ginger and uh he is he actually i just
saw tickets going on sale he's gonna be
playing up in red rock soon or late
later side note anyway
listen to that song but it talks about
how tough that industry is for people
working in it it's a tough tough tough
industry all right so let's fast forward
when did you see a computer first and
then what was your thoughts
first computer i had was a texas
instruments ti 99 4a
my thoughts were hey what games can i
play on this damn thing
um
from there it was uh i had the vic-20
had the commodore 64. had the trs the
radio shack tandy 80 had that uh the
first crime i committed on computers i
had a it was a packard bell so we're
talking uh early mid-90s as far as first
crime on computers
dial-up modem uh started out as a 9600
and was happy as shit when the 28 eights
came so because it was like oh shit this
is fast no it wasn't fast but uh my
initial crimes were very i mean just
very low tech scams uh the first real
internet crime i committed and i talked
about this in a lot of presentations but
i had gotten married i had fi i'd
financed my marriage by faking a car
accident got the insurance money to get
married moved from hazard kentucky up to
lexington kentucky
and i was working at lexmark at that
point in time i had like 60 hour a week
workload 18-hour class load all that
shit something had to give what gave was
the job and what i do is you know you
got to eat didn't really know how and i
find ebay one day and man i like ebay so
didn't know how to make money on ebay
and inside edition ended up giving me a
lot of inspiration
those initial couple of years bill
o'reilly one day
the the television show inside edition
the thirty minute tabloid news yeah they
had a show on beady babies talking about
peanut the royal blue elephant
selling for 1500 on ebay and my dumb ass
i was sitting there thinking well shit i
go down surely one of these hallmark
stores in kentucky has got a peanut
somewhere so i skip class the next day
start visiting the stores figure out you
know after three hours of that figure
out we'll know they don't have it
because his ass is on ebay for fifteen
hundred dollars idiot
but uh what i did was i bought a gray
elephant for eight dollars stopped by
kroger on the way home picked up a pack
of blue dye went home dyed the guy blue
and uh
well yeah this guy you work man it
sounds like it sounds like it until you
realize well the damn thing's made out
of polyester it doesn't hold dye very
well get it out it looks like it's got
the mange
and uh
but i ripped the lady off i found a
picture of a real one online posted it
she she thought i had the real thing she
wins the bid i sent her a message the
message was hey i don't know if i can
trust you we've never done any business
before what i need you to do is go down
and get a us postal money order for
fifteen hundred dollars
once i get that i'll cash it out send
you your animal she believed that
sends me the money orders i cash them
out send her this animal in the mail
get a phone call i didn't order this my
response lady you ordered a blue
elephant sent you a blue-ish elephant
and uh what i found out and that that's
that's one of the problems with a lot of
these scams is
if you delay one of these victims over
and over and over a lot of them get
exasperated they throw their hands in
there and they just give up and none of
them really ever report or complain to
law enforcement so you walk away with
that money and it sends a message to you
at the same time hey i got away with
this this makes money i'll keep going
and i did and i got better at it as i
went along until finally i'm pirating
software pirating software leads into
installing mod chips first into gaming
systems playstation one sega saturn and
then finally that leads into mod chips
and cable boxes so you can watch the
pay-per-view then mod then
the playboy channel and the playboy oh
yeah you got to get your porn and your
wwe pay-per-view oh same people watch
both stone coast steve austin man same
time
did that and got to where i was that led
into
programming satellite dss cards those 18
inch rca satellite systems you can pull
the card out of it program it turn on
all the channels started doing that and
at almost the same time i started doing
that a canadian judge
ruled that it was legal for canadian
citizens to pirate those signals
so what happens is almost overnight
industry pops up in the united states
you go down to best buy buy the system
for a hundred dollars take it out
parking lot open it up pull pull the
system out pull the cart out throw the
system away program the card send it to
canada 500 a pop
started doing that
pulling about 4k a week at that point
had so many orders could not fill them
all quickly thought to myself shit why
do i need to fill any of them they're in
canada i'm down here
who are they going to complain to
you they're not coming so
stole even more money at that point and
got worried about how much was coming in
i started worrying about money
laundering so figure the best thing that
i could do is get a fake id
use that to open up a bank account
launder the money through that cash out
at the atm
no idea where to get a fake id so get
online look around think i find a guy
send him 200 send him my picture
rips me off he scams me yeah
so
how did that feel motherfucker
how did it feel i still feel bad about
that shit today
you're still looking for him
i found it hey no no i ain't still
looking for him i found him later on
yeah i found him later on
in person
well no but i i he was he was dealt with
let's uh so
so what happened so what happens is is
that leads into
shadow crew coming into play because
before there's three sites there's
counterfeit library there's shadow crew
and then there's carter planet i built
and ran both counterfeit library and
shadow group
shadow crew solved a problem for online
crime before those two sites come into
being the only avenue you had to commit
organized crime was an irc chat session
this internet relay chat no idea who
you're talking to if you can trust them
anything else shadow crew
gave a trust mechanism for criminals to
use now you could trust your criminal
associates and you knew if they knew
what they were talking about if products
or services were any good any number of
things like that so that's that's the
change that happens at that point and
that's why i get that that term of
original internet godfather is that all
right um the fake the the guy who ripped
me off i was running shadow crew i think
we had transitioned to shadow crew at
that point i've been running those sites
for about three years
and one day because i'm at the top of
the heat a guy comes to me and he's like
hey man you were ripped off by this fake
id man right and i was like yeah he's
like i know who he is and i was like
well shit who is he
and
i announced it that we played a game of
hangman on on shadow crew i had the had
a little graphic up there with a little
hangman and i was like hey we're gonna
we're gonna play a game with this guy
and uh posted his real name and i was
like i'd appreciate if anybody ever
takes care of him for me and no idea
what happened but
i never heard from the guy again i guess
they we had guys that like max butler
would send child porn to somebody's
address and then oh shit yeah shit like
that
well and that's what i was going to ask
when you say you was dealt with i was
you know it's one of those deals
someone's pounding on the front yeah and
i didn't think so i thought it's uh you
guys could probably bree be pretty
creative yeah i mean look at uh one of
my guys is one of the guys that you know
brian krebs at one point had heroin or
some bullshit sent to him that that was
one of my guys that did that shit all
right after i went to prison everything
he hadn't went to prison and this guy
figures he's going to get brian krebs so
sends brian krebs some heroin then
immediately calls the law enforcement
says hey he's got heroin
and of course law enforcement didn't
fall for that bullshit but uh and he
gets into the guy who sent it gets
indicted later on for that as well
but yeah we were we were we were crazy
we were off the chain yeah you're pretty
creative i mean we we've done some stuff
uh through the years of of co-workers
where
somebody i mean this is it sounds so
dumb compared to that but you know
someone's losing hair and you know you
start you sign them up for hair club for
men bullshit and start showing up at the
office for them or you start sending
erectile dysfunction stuff that comes to
the to their house see that's just
funny that's funny that's exactly it was
done you know done for for jokes
something like that you know what we
would do
we were we were very good about
identifying our members or people who
would rip people off and that's one of
the reasons that shadow crew
takes off the way it does because we had
an environment
that our members were safe from being
scammed and if someone scammed us what i
would typically do
someone scanned a member i would
guarantee every transaction on the site
so if you were scammed by trying to buy
from another person
i would make sure that you were made
whole at the end of the day
and what i'd do is i'd contact the
person who scammed them i'd say hey man
this doesn't want to fly you got to make
this right
and if it was basically you know get
fucked at that point we'd crawl up their
ass you know we would which i'd tell
them hey this is way this is going to
end i'll get it to the point where your
family will look funny look at you real
funny at thanksgiving
and they'll talk about you all the time
do you really want to do that and um
typically
because we had already set examples on
people you know max butler with a child
porn or what have you at that point
they'd make things whole and you
wouldn't have to worry about it and they
would become a very good member at that
point but uh it was rare we had to do
that with the only violence that we ever
saw
script
a real name dmitri golabov he's a
ukrainian guy he's the guy that's
responsible for a modern credit card
theft
he had been he had been in this game it
was the last the last days of shadow
crew like the last 18 months of shadow
crew one day
he starts posting pictures he had had a
guy that owed him money has the guy
kidnapped and tortured
and uh script post pictures of that shit
and then sends a message hey never steal
from me again
so that was that was what happened there
but uh and this is not a violent crew at
all no no and this dimitri guy you're
talking about um you know they were also
involved of what like
i guess the early days of selling drugs
wholesale something like that online as
well right right so so what happens is
it's really interesting so one of the
rules that we had three rules with
shadow crew the rules were hey we don't
sell drugs we don't deal in counterfeit
currency and we do not do child porn
stuff all right those were the rules and
later on i found out well max butler's
been sending people child porn shit for
years
but uh
so what happened is is the only rule
that we ever really lived by was the no
child porn we we ended up the
the last two years of shadow crew we
initially started to allow in marijuana
then it was ecstasy and then from there
it was oxycontin and it just went crazy
because the profit potential on drugs
was much higher than anything we were
seeing on the fraud-based side of things
and same thing for counterfeit currency
i mean the counterfeit currency we had
super bills in there we had the
thomas cook travelers checks things like
that that generated a lot of profit but
the most profit we ever saw was the was
the drug trafficking stuff i mean easily
the best the most profit
and did you uh
you know being the the boss so to speak
with ceo or whatever the title is were
you making you know money yourself off
of the transactions that were happening
on there or you know how were you i
guess financially rewarded for for your
involvement in this
so
back then nowadays it's interesting
nowadays now if you're running a
marketplace
you make like a nickel off every single
transaction that's there that's why ross
ulbricht ends up with 24 million dollars
with a bitcoin that's why these profits
are like that because you've got so many
people that are typically coming in and
buying drugs you make a nickel dime off
every transaction back then we didn't
have that type of tool or system in
place it hadn't been developed yet so no
i didn't i didn't profit from the
transactions that were there what i
profited from
was the sharing of information
that the the access to tools and
services being at the top of the heap
like that people would typically if they
had an exploit a vulnerability or a new
target or anything else you got that
first
so
i had access to that type of information
at the same time
i was very good about
figuring out new types of crime so i'm
the guy that invents tax return identity
theft i'm the first seller of
fraudulent bank accounts online i had
all these things these so my convictions
i've got 39 convictions those 39
convictions were all about refining and
implementing new cyber crimes that we
see today so if you if you want a guy to
point at that's responsible for identity
theft uh synthetic fraud tax return
identity theft fishing schemes all that
i was on the ground floor of a lot of of
that on developing it and refining it
and everything
it's tax return identity theft
so the reason your returns the reason
that your tax return is delayed every
single year as the son of a bitch you're
talking to right now
that's a fact that's a fact so uh
so what happened was is
the first database that i had access to
was the indiana state sex offenders
registry and i i got access to that it
had the socials the dl numbers the
mother's maiden dates of birth they had
all the information you'd need and my
thought process was shit they're
pedophiles nobody's going to care if you
exploit and victimize them
so
i i use their identities to set up
fraudulent bank accounts to launder
money and i either use those accounts
personally or i sold those to people who
needed to launder money
we hit that so hard that indiana changes
that database they start to strip the
pii out of that database so the next
database once that became useless the
next database was the texas driver's
license database where you had full
access to all the driver's license files
that were in that database
use that and mined that out for a few
months and then finally the last
database i had access to was the
california death registry so got access
to that it had mother's maiden social
security number all this other stuff to
it and my initial thought was you know i
wonder
if you could use dead people to file for
social security benefits that way you
get a recurring paycheck all the time
well that that requires a lot of uh
research to figure out stuff how does
the government know you're dead you know
how how can you exploit this what's the
system on on uh social security
everything else so you research lots of
stuff then you start to run tests
basically try to file for unemployed for
social security claims you find out
pretty quickly that shit don't work
because that number has been dormant for
so long they want you to come in for a
physical interview somebody that's in
their 30s can't pass for somebody that's
approaching 70. so that shit was out so
the next idea i had was well i wonder if
somebody could file
tax returns
on dead people turns out you can and you
can steal a lot of money doing that so
uh
i started i'm the guy that started to do
that bullshit got to where i was
following manually one return every six
minutes i'd profit about 160k a week 10
months out of the year
that is what is what leads into when you
see all these cyber crime and cyber
security warnings about make sure your
tax returns are secure and everything it
starts with dead people but you quickly
transition over to stealing living
people's documents as well and filing
returns for them i'm the guy that
started that online fraud like that
brad let me ask you when when you said
you had access to these databases was it
again is this something like you hacked
into was it something through
you know through your social engineering
your group that basically somebody in
there either hacked into it they had a
family member that worked there you know
that blah blah blah one of those type of
things now we had insiders at some dmvs
uh at the knoxville dmv we had an
insider that you can go in and get a
real driver's license all right but
what you're going to find out is this
idea of hacking this thing where you
know all cyber criminals are hackers no
you're not you're not there's very
little hacking that goes on back then
most of these databases had ac had
public not public access but access was
there and could be easily found
the the stat that matters these days
there's a few stats but the big one for
that is that 80 percent of everyone uses
the same password across multiple
websites so you you phish somebody out
you know you get their their login for
their streaming service or whatever they
may be using the same login at work
so you can get access like that you've
got you've got all these exploits that
are out there that have nothing to do
with hacking whatsoever it's simply
human error it's it's vulnerabilities
that have been talked about and preached
about that nobody's plugged and that
tends to be the threat landscape that's
out there even on nation-state attacks a
lot of nation-state attacks are not
hacks they're just simply
exploiting the known vulnerabilities
that have been around for years
well speaking of known vulnerabilities
how's that that's pretty good
um yeah
before we got on here with
you today i kind of looked at some of
the statistics just on
fraud and things like that going on the
ftc reports in 2021 their number was 5.8
billion dollars in fraud which is up uh
70 from just 2020 and they said you know
last year roughly 2.8 million people
reported some sort of you know fraud
like that so and it does it just keeps
growing and growing and just like you
said it's not
whiz kids like you see in the movie that
are part of a big crew and you know one
guy is known for explosives one guy's
good for stealing cars one guy's the
computer the computer guy it's not like
that it's just exactly like you said
it's you know it's a criminal mindset
um that is that is pretty smart and
determined and looks for
areas that they can exploit well you
know it's it's it's interesting when you
think about it i mean the good guys
you take somebody that's that's a fraud
analyst or one of these cyber security
professionals it's a job
you know hopefully you're going home at
night and you're not worrying about that
shit on the criminal side it's not a job
it's a lifestyle
that's a big difference i mean this is
something that's 24 hours a day seven
days a week you don't put it to bed it's
constant that lifestyle that mindset
it's constant so the hours are against
you the numbers are against you we ended
shadow crew with 4 000 members fast
forward to 2017 the largest criminal
group called alpha bay it ends with 240
000 members fast forward two more years
the alphabet was on the dark web it was
ran by a guy in thailand
named alexander kazaa all right and he
he gets caught in thailand he promptly
hangs himself
for sure well he was a canadian he was a
canadian guy he was just living in
thailand but he hangs himself because
exactly
but he he hangs himself because he was
going to get life in prison he just
checks out
so fast forward two more years from 2017
to 2019
the largest website black market
1.15 million members and that's
pre-pandemic so during the pandemic you
had the government instituting stimulus
programs with absolutely no security in
place
fraud blew up at that point you had 16
year olds on telegram that were stealing
60 000 a week on unemployment fraud and
you're you pointed it out i'll say it
again those peop those kids
they're they're not criminal geniuses
you simply go to one of these forums one
of these channels and they'll walk you
through
how to commit this type of crime and
it's profitable and the chances of being
caught very very slim
well and even if you are caught the the
the prosecution
uh you know what what's actually going
to happen is very very slim and we'll
kind of get into yours you obviously did
do some prison time but most people in
these type of things you'll kind of get
a restitution you'll get a probation
don't do it again right um stay away
from computers well hell i'll i'll put
this out here just stay away from
computers just last week uh
you know i've had credit card fraud
that's happened before but just last
week i had a credit reporting agency i
was i was checking on my my credit
report and it showed that my my credit
score had dropped like 50 points and so
i was like what the hell's going on here
i see a number for some um some some
group out of texas i contact them and
there was like a 2200 balance where
somebody used my information went into a
store in oklahoma city which is you know
about 100 miles from us in tulsa with my
name my social security number and
opened up a couple a t and t cell phone
lines and it's like 2 200 bucks they owe
so you know that's just uh
you know a quick hustle somebody's
walking away with a couple phones and
obviously you know how to do the police
report and you know so forth so it's
just there's so many different ways that
people can explain there's there's a lot
of different ways i mean that that phone
hustle scam whatever you want to call it
the extremely common a lot of these
phone stores have insiders that help out
with that but you don't even need the
insider to do that you simply go in with
the information and you've got the
phones right there so you know i've got
i i run two phones i run the one i
recently bought i got that samsung s22
ultra that's like a 1300 phone well you
get the damn if you're scamming one out
if you're going into cell phone store
and getting one of these things how much
can you get for it on craigslist you can
get an easy thousand all day every day
so if you're if you're running two of
these
at one store that's two thousand dollars
how many can how many stores can you hit
in a week you take a road trip you can
hit a whole shitload of stores like that
in a week
yep all right so we're gonna jump fast
forward you eventually
do get jammed up oh yeah how the hell
how the hell they catch your ass i mean
you were you were obviously good you had
a good hustle going you were surrounded
by people that were in the same business
somebody snitch on you undercover
operation so what happens is we uh we
had this thing called the cvv1 breach or
hack so on the back of your creditor
debit card
that magnetic stripe has three data
tracks the second data track is what's
bought and sold on criminal marketplaces
it's the it's called the dump it's the
card number forward slash
16-digit algorithm outside of it that's
what you have to have when you swipe a
card or you insert the card into an atm
to get money out all right now we were
doing all this fishing all these fishing
schemes we were getting the card numbers
we're getting the pins but for that to
encode and withdraw money in atm you
have to have that algorithm that's on
track too
can't generate it can't guess it got to
know it what we quickly discovered is
that none of the banks had implemented
the hash on track two what that actually
means is you could take the card number
a forward slash any 16 digits out beside
of it it would encode and you could take
it to an atm because you already had the
pin you could take it to the atm start
withdrawing cash we started to do that
now before we started to do that and it
was it was wide open on every single
bank small banks big banks every bank
was wide open for this exploit
before we started to do that we were
doing basic online credit card fraud and
a good carter could profit 30 to 40 000
a month all right
once that breach happened once that hack
happened
that 30 to 40 000 a month changed to 30
to 40 thousand dollars a day and that
attracted law enforcement attention
because you had thousands of people that
were doing that
so we quickly started to see ip numbers
coming in from government agencies we
started to see state and local law
enforcement websites that were talking
about shadow crew the forums were
talking about shadow crew
so we got worried about that at the same
time we had a guy named enhance you guys
may remember this but paris hilton
back around 2003
she had her phone list published her
t-mobile phone contact list was
published and there was a lot of news
about that shit
that was one of our guys
and that was not a hack
yeah right right
that was not a hack that was an insider
he worked at t-mobile she had t-mobile
so he got her phone list published that
shit at the same time
he intercepted text messages of the
secret service investigating us and
published that so the writing was on the
wall our days were numbered now
we hired this guy
named uh albert gonzalez he was our
forum techy he was handling all the
software that that shadow crew was
operating on everything else like that
albert was involved in those atm cash
outs so this kid i i guess he was like
20 years old at the time
this this guy
one day he's in new jersey he's standing
at an atm broad daylight for 40 minutes
he's got a stack of white plastic
counterfeit cards and he's putting one
card
yeah he's a dumbass he's putting one
card in taking 20 bills out stuffing
them in a backpack does this shit for 40
minutes broad daylight he's wearing a
wig all this other stuff meanwhile just
so happens across the street two new
jersey cops are looking at this kid
asking themselves what the shit is going
on finally one cop looks at the other
he's like let me see what's going on
here after 40 minutes he gets up walks
over looks at albert kid what are you
doing albert's got the disguise he's got
the wig falls apart right there
confesses to everything
partners with the united states secret
service
secret service had no i mean they knew
what was going on but they were very
unskilled at that point nowadays they're
very very confident back then they
weren't but they asked him i was like
how would you catch these guys albert's
like well we could run a vpn
so they were like good idea so i because
the writing was on the wall
that
our days were numbered i ended up
quitting shadow crew before albert comes
back in and institutes the vpn so i walk
away
meanwhile albert comes into shadow crew
installs the vpn has all the traffic go
through that and that's where the
indictments the identifications come
through so shadow crew makes the front
cover of forbes august 2004 headline
who's stealing your identity october 26
2004 united states secret service arrest
33 people six countries six hours i'm
the only guy publicly mentioned is
getting away they pick me up four months
later give me a job and i'm the son of a
bitch that continues to break the law
from inside secret service offices for
the next 10 months until they find out
about it i take off on a cross-country
crime spree still six hundred thousand
dollars in four months make the united
states most wanted list go to disney
world get arrested sent to prison escape
from prison get arrested again serve out
my time
[Laughter]
yeah what what a role model that is
what why'd you pick disneyland i was so
i i stole 160k out of atms the night
before woke up the next morning i was
united states most wanted and it was a
joke i was i sat there kind of stunned
like holy shit man and i said it out
loud i was like well brett you've made
the united states most wanted list what
now and i said i'm going to disney world
and i sat there and i thought about it
and i was like shit i'm going to disney
world so i was like i figured i could
hole up there about a year i was i was
trying to bug out to uh to brazil in
disney world yeah i was going i was
going to hold up in orlando go to the
park
they had the parks they had the strip
clubs i was like we'll go there so uh
okay so how did you escape prison
this wasn't a maximum
you know it's nowhere near as romantic
as it sounds what happens is is my dad i
hadn't talked to him for about 20 years
the man starts to come visit me in
prison about the third third visit in he
looks at me he's like you know i've been
reading about you online i was like yeah
he's like he's like that's a lot of
money you made and i was like yeah he's
like you think you could teach somebody
how to make that money and i was like
yeah
so
i used to say that i used to lie about
it and say you know i thought the man
was back in my life and he broke my
heart the truth of the matter was as i
manipulated the man
into helping me escape
in in exchange for teaching him how to
do this fraud
so i was at a minimum security prison i
had him drop off the change of clothes
4000 in cash an id and a phone and i had
a job outside of the fence and i was at
the prison about six weeks
took off i was out
i was out for about three weeks had
already set up shop on identity theft
again
u.s marshals will canvassing a
three-state area and they find me and i
went back to prison served eight months
in solitary confinement and they shipped
me out to a real prison
out in west texas where
they get your ride out there
they do they get your mind right
well bro so brett when once you uh you
serve your time twice um you get
released and
kind of you alluded to it at the
beginning um you know obviously life is
turned around doing different things
you're kind of helping
i guess businesses as well as the
government and whatnot for you know for
people like yourself so how did that get
started in um you know probably lastly
man how can people
like ourselves avoid being the victim so
i i was uh you know i've been very
fortunate i was given as as the story
you know just the short time i've talked
to you guys today you can see i had
opportunity upon opportunity to turn my
life around the secret service tried to
help me out i screwed them over i mean i
had opportunities throughout my life to
turn things around i just squandered
them uh i got out of prison in 2011 i i
did violate probation after that but the
three things that turned my life around
were my sister
she had disowned me for a time that came
back in my life my wife now michelle she
showed me what a healthy relationship
was and then finally the fbi a guy named
keith milarski he's retired now but
keith milarski out of the pittsburgh
office guy took me under his wing gave
me references advice everything else
those three things were the turnaround
but more
on top of that
i had people in the industry in the
cyber security and cyber crimes you know
that world that gave me the opportunity
to make a living so today i've
i'm chief criminal officer for arcos
labs that's the first one on the planet
that's been announced like that i'm a
spokesperson for aarp
speak across the planet i've got a
couple podcasts down working on books
and documentaries and all this stuff
i lead a very blessed life that i
let's be honest i lead a blessed life
that i damn well don't deserve but i'm
damn grateful to have and i make the
most of it every single day
about trying to help and protect people
from that type of guy i used to be um
you ask how how can you protect yourself
these days it's it's actually not that
hard man it's uh there's three main
things that everyone needs to do the
first thing is you need to freeze the
credit on every single person in the
house every person including kids
because kids are the number one victims
of identity theft 25
will be a victim of id theft so freeze
everyone's credit it's free it's been
free since 2018.
so freeze your credit uh the second
thing is is monitor your accounts and
place alerts on those accounts so like
your credit cards place a zero dollar
alert on that
so you get some son of a bitch like me
that goes on the dark web and buys your
credit card details i ping it just to
see if it's alive you get a text message
saying hey someone's trying to use it so
freeze credit monitor accounts place
alerts and then the big one passwords
eighty percent of everyone uses the same
password across multiple websites so use
a password manager it changes the
passwords it generates passwords for you
everything else like that use a password
manager
and those three things just those three
things will protect you far more than
most anything else you can do and most
most anything that 90 of the population
is doing right now
well brett honestly man this has been
one of our uh without a doubt or one of
our most unique guests we've had on here
with unique podcast and uh man it's been
an absolute pleasure fantastic yeah
absolutely one of the smartest criminals
we've had
definitely one of the most handsome yeah
i like that i like that oh
smart yeah let's be honest hey you know
hey you know they i mean you've probably
heard of yourself we don't catch the
smart ones right that's the that's what
you know kind of what we say on the job
we don't catch a smart one so
what sounds like you were treating it
like a job you know it was the family
tradition it was just a job
let me one last hey uh i appreciate you
guys having me on truth
last question brett and then uh man plug
your plug you know where everybody can
find you whether it's your podcast or
your website and things like that i know
you do a lot of public speaking um get
you out there for sure more than you
already are
if you look back at the totality of your
time doing that type of stuff have you
ever tried to place an approximate
monetary number that you solely whether
it's responsible for benefited from
anything like that
yeah i stole about seven million that's
what i stole it's a good chunk of money
okay
i mean it's it is and uh it's a lot of
victims it is that's what it is yep
absolutely all right brett where can
everybody find you how can they get a
hold of you and listen to your podcast
so
where can you find me i just i just
started this new show called the brett
johnson show it's on youtube we're going
to be on spotify as soon as i get around
to it but the brett johnson show check
that out you can find me on linkedin as
well you can do a google search for me
hell do that too brett johnson
cybercrime i'll pop up there you guys
need anything do not hesitate to reach
out i really do take it seriously
about trying to help people be protected
against that type of guy used to be
brett we do appreciate it brother be
safe yeah thanks very much thank you
filmmaker stay safe